Quickest intro ever. Go. Hey, this is Jason. Hey, this is Sean Hayes. Hey, it's Will. And this is... ...Smarlas. Let's try that again.
史上最快开场。开始。嘿，我是杰森。嘿，我是肖恩·海耶斯。嘿，我是威尔。这是……Smarlas。我们再试一次。
Okay. Hey, Jason here. Hey, Sean here. Hey, it's Will here. And this is... And producers... Sorry, we're going quick because of producers. They wanted to know what...
好的。嘿，杰森在这儿。嘿，肖恩在这儿。嘿，威尔在这儿。这是……还有制片人……抱歉，因为制片人的原因我们要快点。他们想知道什么……
They wanted to be... You should get on to it. Yeah, go, go, go, go, go. Go. Smarlas. Quicker, please. Hey, listener. You are listening to the quickest intro for Smarlas yet.
他们想成为……你应该开始了。对，快，快，快，快，快。开始。Smarlas。请快点。嘿，听众。你正在收听Smarlas有史以来最快的开场。
Hi, listener. It's Sean. Jason. Hey, it's Will. Hey, it's Will. And it's Sean. This is a show we do. It's called Smarlas.
嗨，听众。我是肖恩。杰森。嘿，我是威尔。嘿，我是威尔。我是肖恩。这是我们做的节目。它叫Smarlas。
It's a podcast that we talk... Wait, Sean. That was already too long. That was already too long. Here we go. Hey, ready? Here we go. Hey, listener.
这是一个我们谈论……等等，肖恩。那已经太长了。那已经太长了。我们开始吧。嘿，准备好了吗？我们开始吧。嘿，听众。
My name is Sean. Jason here. Will. And this is a podcast that we do where we talk to people about stuff. Ready? It's called Smarlas. And here we go. Oh, my God.
我叫肖恩。杰森在这儿。威尔。这是一个我们做的播客，我们和人们谈论各种事情。准备好了吗？它叫Smarlas。我们开始吧。天哪。
Unbelievable. We're about to hear the quickest intro for Smarlas yet. It's Smarlas. It's Smarlas. And I'm... No. Almost. Hey, listener.
难以置信。我们即将听到Smarlas有史以来最快的开场。这是Smarlas。这是Smarlas。我是……不。差不多。嘿，听众。
You're about to hear the quickest intro for Smarlas yet. I'm Jason. Sean. Will. Smarlas. Nice. I just want to use that whole take. Hey, guys, it's been a while.
你即将听到Smarlas有史以来最快的开场。我是杰森。肖恩。威尔。Smarlas。不错。我只想用刚才那整段录音。嘿，伙计们，好久不见。
We haven't seen each other in like a week. No. How have you been? I think it was just a day or so ago, wasn't it? Oh. Wasn't it? Was it really? Was it?
我们大概有一周没见了。不。你最近怎么样？我觉得大概是一两天前吧，不是吗？哦。不是吗？真的是吗？是吗？
No. It was at the weekend, I'm pretty sure. Oh, so maybe that was like four or five days ago. What's today? Today's Tuesday. Today's Tuesday. Well, you know, my day off, my days off are Mondays. And Scottie and I went to the Field Museum here in Chicago.
不。我肯定是在周末。哦，那可能是四五天前了。今天是星期几？今天是星期二。今天是星期二。嗯，你知道，我的休息日是星期一。我和斯科蒂去了芝加哥的菲尔德博物馆。
Yeah. Which is, you know, you go see... Oh, that's where all the old fields are. Yeah. No. No. Jason's being funny. Fields of Dream.
对。就是，你知道，你去参观……哦，那是所有老菲尔德（Fields）所在的地方。不。不。杰森在开玩笑。梦幻之地（Fields of Dream）。
No, you go... There's like the dinosaur stuff you learn about. And you see how the earth started, like it's from the very beginning. And it was like, it's really cool to see the dinosaur bones up close. You don't believe the evolution garbage, do you? No. Okay. Good.
不，你去……那里有恐龙之类的东西，你可以学习。你还能看到地球是如何开始的，就像从最开始一样。近距离观察恐龙骨骼真的很酷。你不相信进化论那种垃圾，对吧？不。好的。很好。
No, that's... So you're looking at... So the dinosaur stuff. And I was like... And I always wonder like, are those the actual bones? They can't be, right? Right. So then they have those guys with the picture...
不，那是……所以你在看……所以是恐龙的东西。我当时想……我总是好奇，那些是真正的骨头吗？不可能是吧？对。然后他们有那些拿着相机的家伙……
With the cameras that come up to you like at amusement parks, right? Where they take your picture and they're like, well, we're gonna charge you. And I was like, I just called up my phone. I was like, I'll just take my own photo. Rude. Right. You know, these guys got to make a living too, Sean.
就像在游乐园里走到你面前的那些人，对吧？他们给你拍照，然后说，我们要收费。我当时就拿出手机，我说，我自己拍一张就行了。粗鲁。对。你知道，这些人也要谋生，肖恩。
I know. Jason just turned 53. Three. Yeah. Three. Not just. And Amanda said that they still get... You're still...
我知道。杰森刚满53岁。三岁。对。三岁。不是刚满。阿曼达说他们仍然……你仍然……
They still get frisky, but she refers to him as dinosaur bone. So... Yeah. Meaning... You know. Yeah. I don't know. You know, that's a...
他们仍然很有活力，但她称他为恐龙骨头。所以……对。意思是……你知道。对。我不知道。你知道，那是一个……
It's not a bad question or observation, Sean. Thank you. I'm gonna go with it for a minute here. About the real bones, I mean? Yeah, because so they do go through... The archaeologists, they go through there and they pick and they sweep and they brush and they pull them out. And then what do they do with them?
肖恩，这不是一个糟糕的问题或观察。谢谢。我打算在这儿多聊一会儿。你是说关于真正的骨头吗？对，因为他们确实会经历……考古学家，他们会去那里，挑选、清扫、刷洗，然后把它们取出来。然后他们会对它们做什么？
They probably have to encase them and complete them in some form. Right. And so the real stuff is probably underneath some sort of sheath of plastic that is meant to look like a bone, right? Right, but here's my thing. Why rope the area off if it's not the real bones? Because it makes it feel like it's real and a little bit more of an ooh and an ah effect. I don't know.
他们可能必须把它们封装起来，并以某种形式补全。对。所以真正的骨头可能在某种塑料外壳下面，看起来像骨头，对吧？对，但我的问题是。如果不是真正的骨头，为什么要用绳子把那个区域围起来？因为这让人感觉它是真的，而且有一种“哇”的效果。我不知道。
I don't know. Will? Anything? No, you find that stuff interesting? Will doesn't even want to play with this nonsense. Okay? He's... It's so...
我不知道。威尔？有什么想说的吗？不，你觉得那些东西有趣吗？威尔甚至不想参与这种废话。好吗？他……这太……
To be honest... You don't like museums. You don't like museums. Please don't lie. Just listening... Please don't lie. And no more. It's like it's the conjecture junction.
老实说……你不喜欢博物馆。你不喜欢博物馆。请不要撒谎。只是听着……请不要撒谎。别再说了。这就像是推测交汇处。
It's just like, I think that. Maybe that. Just look it up for fuck's sake. I know. I gotta look it up. Hey, you know what, Elshon? The folks behind the glass in the... What do you call it?
就像是，我想是那样。也许是那样。看在上帝的份上，查一下吧。我知道。我得查一下。嘿，你知道吗，埃尔肖恩？玻璃后面的那些人……你管那叫什么？
The... What do you call it? Behind the glass where they have the sort of the pictures of the animals. It's a real setting. Oh, like a diorama? Right. They're not real either. Wait, what?
那个……你管那叫什么？玻璃后面有动物图片的地方。那是一个真实的场景。哦，像立体模型吗？对。它们也不是真的。等等，什么？
Yeah, the guy with the heavy brow. Not breathing. But they did have these animals behind the glass. And when I walked in, I said to Scott, I'm like, is that like the real thing that they just stuffed it from like, you know, 200 BC? Also, also a decent question. Well, why are you cranky today? I don't know.
对，那个眉头紧锁的家伙。没有呼吸。但他们确实在玻璃后面放了这些动物。当我走进去时，我对斯科特说，我问，那是他们从公元前200年左右填充的真东西吗？这也是个不错的问题。好吧，你今天为什么这么暴躁？我不知道。
I don't know. I'm hungry. Uh-oh. You want to pause and go grab a bar? It's dinner time. It's not dinner time. Oh, now, now Sean's going to start getting it. You know, listener, Sean's making us jump through impossible hoops.
我不知道。我饿了。噢。你想暂停一下去拿个能量棒吗？现在是晚餐时间。现在不是晚餐时间。哦，现在，现在肖恩要开始发作了。你知道，听众朋友们，肖恩让我们跳过不可能的障碍。
Yeah, impossible hoops. To continue bringing you the joy and the ear candy that is smart less. We're recording this at 5 p.m. Okay? Yeah, but when do we do it? Who works at 5 p.m.? Not me. Everybody.
对，不可能的障碍。为了继续给你们带来Smartless的快乐和听觉享受。我们现在是下午5点录音。好吗？对，但我们什么时候做这个？谁下午5点工作？不是我。所有人。
Oh. Usually it's a nice morning thing when we've got our attitude, our energy, our rest. By the way, we can do mornings riddled with guilt about it. Ready? Here we go. No, don't. You're an easy target. Let's get to the guest, yes?
哦。通常这是一个美好的早晨活动，那时我们有态度、有精力、有休息。顺便说一句，我们可以带着负罪感在早上做。准备好了吗？我们开始吧。不，别。你是个容易受攻击的目标。我们谈谈嘉宾吧，好吗？
I'm so excited too that you guys are going to be... Nothing more about museums? Frithful, I've never heard somebody describe themselves as so excited with less excitement. Oh my God. Oh my God. What about our guest? No, about yourself. About yourself.
我也很兴奋你们要……关于博物馆没别的话说了吗？弗里斯福，我从来没听过有人用这么缺乏兴奋感的方式形容自己很兴奋。天哪。天哪。我们的嘉宾呢？不，关于你自己。关于你自己。
I'm so excited too. No, I'm so excited. No, this guy, I can't wait to just get his... Is it somebody with more intelligence than us that can shine a light on the whole thing? That's the other thing too. I got to say that that's the other thing too. I sometimes get nervous about we go down these holes about info before we know who the guest is. And I'm like, this person thinks we're a fucking idiot.
我也很兴奋。不，我很兴奋。不，这个家伙，我迫不及待想得到他的……他是那种比我们聪明、能照亮整个事情的人吗？这也是另一回事。我得说这也是另一回事。有时我很紧张，因为我们在知道嘉宾是谁之前就陷入了这些信息黑洞。我当时想，这个人觉得我们是白痴。
Yeah, that's why they're here. Well, that ship has sailed. That's why they're here because there's no threat coming on you. So listen, I'm super excited. I've been a fan of this guy for a very, very, very long time. He's had two very popular shows back to back where the first one ran from 1993 to 2002. That's nine years. And then the next one, which ran from 2003 to present day, which is almost 20 years.
对，这就是他们来这儿的原因。好吧，那艘船已经开走了。这就是他们来这儿的原因，因为你身上没有威胁。所以听着，我超级兴奋。我做这个家伙的粉丝已经很久很久了。他连续有两个非常受欢迎的节目，第一个从1993年播到2002年。那是九年。然后是下一个，从2003年播到现在，已经快20年了。
Kelsey Grammer? No. He's asked me on his show a couple of times, but like a tiny, tiny coward. I was too scared because news flash, I'm not the brightest bulb. And I feared people might just start to pick up on that. He started his career as a standup and an actor, but thank God he tossed out the actor part. Otherwise, I wouldn't know where to get my news of the week from. Guys, it's the super funny, super smart Bill Maher.
凯尔西·格拉玛？不。他曾几次邀请我上他的节目，但我像个胆小鬼。我太害怕了，因为新闻快讯，我不是最聪明的灯泡。我担心人们可能会开始注意到这一点。他以单口喜剧演员和演员的身份开始职业生涯，但谢天谢地他抛弃了演员的部分。否则，我就不知道从哪里获取每周新闻了。伙计们，他就是超级有趣、超级聪明的比尔·马赫。
Hello. Oh, Bill Maher. Christ, Bill can tell us about bones and stuff. Yes. Bill's super smart. Yeah, but not about bones. Come on. Bill, are the folks in the diorama real?
你好。哦，比尔·马赫。天哪，比尔可以告诉我们关于骨头之类的事情。是的。比尔超级聪明。是的，但不是关于骨头。得了吧。比尔，立体模型里的那些人是真的吗？
They're not real, are they? No, but I have fond memories of my childhood making dioramas. That was the whole thing. I wonder if kids even know what that word is or do they do that anymore? Can you do it on your phone? I needed help. I used to make them. I used to make those little things all the time.
他们不是真的，对吧？不，但我对童年制作立体模型的记忆很深刻。那是整件事的重点。我不知道孩子们是否还知道那个词，或者他们还做那种事吗？你能在手机上做吗？我需要帮助。我过去常做。我过去常做那些小东西。
Yeah. With the little people inside and you hang them on a string. I wish I saved them. I could have sold them on eBay now for great money. Bill, I want to say to you, first of all, thank you for coming on. And as you know, I've emailed you through the years. We've chatted through the years. I'm just, I hold you in the highest regard.
对。里面有小人，你用绳子把它们挂起来。我真希望我保存下来了。我现在可以在eBay上卖个好价钱。比尔，我想对你说，首先，谢谢你来参加。如你所知，多年来我一直给你发邮件。我们多年来一直聊天。我只是，我非常敬重你。
I have never, ever missed one episode of Real Time with Bill Maher. And I appreciate that. And I love you too, by the way. That's pretty close to my record. Yeah. I am truly a fan of all you guys. You're a nice man. But I like Shawn the best.
我从来没有错过《马赫脱口秀》（Real Time with Bill Maher）的任何一集。我很感激。顺便说一句，我也爱你。这很接近我的记录了。是的。我确实是你们所有人的粉丝。你是个好人。但我最喜欢肖恩。
Yeah. I don't blame you a lot. And we also had dinner once. Yes, we did. Yeah, it was great. We had a date. I loved it. Was it at Koi?
对。我不怪你。我们还一起吃过一次晚餐。是的，我们吃过。对，那很棒。我们约会了。我很喜欢。是在Koi吗？
Was it at Koi? Was it at Koi? No, it was not at Koi. It was at Chin Chin. No, it was at Piccolino. Yeah, that's it. Yeah. Ready?
是在Koi吗？是在Koi吗？不，不是在Koi。是在Chin Chin。不，是在Piccolino。对，就是那个。对。准备好了吗？
Oh, there's a little place on Robertson. On Robertson, yeah. You were green. I wore red. Oh, yes. I remember it well. Now, come on, Shawn. You can sing that when you're a master of the musical theater.
哦，罗伯逊街上有个小地方。在罗伯逊街，对。你穿了绿色。我穿了红色。哦，是的。我记得很清楚。得了吧，肖恩。当你成为音乐剧大师时，你可以唱那个。
Come on, Shawn. No, now this show, Smart List, is the opposite of real time in that we asked the most mundane, dumbest questions you possibly think of. And here's one now. I've always wanted to ask you this, but as someone who's as bright as you are, as incredibly quick-witted as you are, how did you end up in the world of political commentary
得了吧，肖恩。不，现在这个节目，Smartless，和《马赫脱口秀》正好相反，我们问的是你能想到的最平凡、最愚蠢的问题。现在就有一个。我一直想问你这个，但作为一个像你一样聪明、像你一样机智的人，你是怎么进入政治评论界的？
when you could have pursued other political avenues? What drew you to politics and build a life around your career around politics? Well, yeah, I was drawn to a career in the show business, not a career in politics. And of course, I don't have a career in politics, but politics as the fodder, you know, the clay I was working with, I think, comes from my childhood.
当你本可以追求其他政治途径时？是什么吸引你进入政治，并围绕政治建立你的职业生涯？嗯，是的，我被吸引的是演艺事业，而不是政治事业。当然，我没有从事政治事业，但政治作为素材，你知道，我所使用的粘土，我认为来自我的童年。
My father was a newsman on radio news. Oh. So, yeah, my father was in news. So we talked about that. It was in my household. It was just part of what seeped into me, you know? That was my household. I don't think that was the typical household. So I always knew what was going on politically.
我父亲是广播新闻的新闻工作者。哦。所以，是的，我父亲从事新闻工作。所以我们谈论过那个。它在我的家庭里。它只是渗入我的一部分，你知道吗？那是我的家庭。我不认为那是典型的家庭。所以我总是知道政治上发生了什么。
I always read the newspaper, even as a teenager. Oh, wow. What part of the world was that, Bill? Where did you grow up? That was the part called New Jersey. OK. So then it was always an interest for you, and then to just sort of naturally find its way into your comedy?
我总是读报纸，即使在十几岁的时候。哦，哇。那是世界的哪个部分，比尔？你在哪里长大的？那是被称为新泽西的部分。好的。所以这对你来说一直是个兴趣，然后自然而然地融入了你的喜剧中？
Yeah. I mean, when you're first doing stand-up, of course, you will say anything to get a laugh. You know, laughter is oxygen when you're on stage and you're like a fish flopping on the dock, you know, gasping for air. So anything that will get a laugh, you will say, and I did, and we all did.
是的。我的意思是，当你刚开始做单口喜剧时，当然，你会说任何话来博取笑声。你知道，当你站在舞台上时，笑声就是氧气，你就像一条在码头上扑腾的鱼，你知道，喘着气。所以任何能博取笑声的话，你都会说，我也说了，我们都说了。
But I slowly gravitated. I mean, my act now, I have a special coming out. HBO, my 13th, if you can believe it, and I'm only 40. Wow. Congratulations. That's awesome. Do you have a date on that yet? I think that's April 15th.
但我慢慢地被吸引了。我的意思是，我现在表演，我有一个特别节目要出来。HBO，我的第13个，如果你能相信的话，而我才40岁。哇。恭喜。那太棒了。你有日期了吗？我想是4月15日。
That drops, as the kids say. Sure. But, you know, there's a good amount of politics in it, and there's a lot of stuff in it that's not political, because I mean, I'm a stand-up first. I'm always drawn to that, and I'm always drawn, as you can see from this conversation, I'm always going to try to wheel it into something a little
正如孩子们所说，它会发布。当然。但是，你知道，里面有相当多的政治内容，也有很多非政治的内容，因为我的意思是，我首先是一个单口喜剧演员。我总是被那个吸引，而且正如你从这次谈话中看到的，我总是试图把它引向一些更……
more substantive. That's just my nature. Yeah, I'm so glad you do. So I feel like I'm fucking up your show. No, no, no. No, no, no. But that's okay. Like, I guess that explains a lot, because what, you know,
更实质性的东西。这是我的天性。是的，我很高兴你这么做。所以我感觉我搞砸了你的节目。不，不，不。不，不，不。但没关系。就像，我想这解释了很多，因为什么，你知道，
what you've done in sort of, dare I say, the late night space, if you will, and just indulge me for a second, is that you've kind of taken what a lot of people did. You know, you had these guys and a lot of amazing, you know, funny guys that we all looked up to, whether it's Letterman or Carson or whatever, and they would have moments where they'd touch on the news
你在深夜节目领域所做的，如果可以这么说的话，请容忍我一下，就是你采取了很多人所做的事情。你知道，你有这些家伙和很多了不起的、有趣的家伙，我们都仰望他们，无论是莱特曼还是卡森什么的，他们会有触及新闻的时刻
and what was going on. You took that slice and you grew it. Yeah. And that became, as you said, the fodder for all your, you know, all your stuff. And that certainly struck a chord with people, because people were like, yeah, I want to talk more about that show.
以及正在发生的事情。你取了那一块并把它扩大了。是的。正如你所说，那成为了你所有东西的素材。这确实引起了人们的共鸣，因为人们会说，是的，我想多谈谈那个节目。
I want to make fun of it. I want to talk about the absurdity of it. I want to talk about it in serious ways. And I want to engage these people on either side of the aisle in ways that is not confrontational, but certainly stripped down and feels like, fuck the bullshit. Just talk to me for real for one.
我想取笑它。我想谈谈它的荒谬之处。我想以严肃的方式谈论它。我想以非对抗性的方式与两党的人接触，但确实剥离了外壳，感觉像是，去他的废话。就跟我说实话吧。
Give me a fucking... What I love is the give me a fucking break aspect of your show. Well, yeah, I mean, I was... When I was in the clubs and starting out, I wanted to be more Johnny Carson. We all did. We wanted to host that kind of, you know, broad vaudevillian variety show.
给我一个该死的……我喜欢你节目中“给我一个该死的休息”的方面。嗯，是的，我当时……当我在俱乐部开始时，我想成为更多的约翰尼·卡森。我们都想。我们想主持那种，你知道，广泛的杂耍综艺节目。
But as I got older, I was like, no, I don't want to talk to, you know, fucking sitcom players. No offense to the people here. Hi. No, I mean, my show is not a celebrity-driven show unless you think Andrew Sullivan, you know, and the governor of Montana are celebrities. You know, it's a political...
但随着年龄增长，我想，不，我不想和那些，你知道，该死的肥皂剧演员交谈。对在座的各位没有冒犯。嗨。不，我的意思是，我的节目不是一个以名人为主导的节目，除非你认为安德鲁·沙利文和蒙大拿州州长是名人。你知道，这是一个政治……
It's mostly... I mean, we do have celebrities on quite often. But informed ones. Yeah, informed ones. Or, you know, just ones... You know, Steve Martin and Martin Short did it last year. Howard Stern has done it at the top as a one-on-one interview. Any of you guys could do it if you wanted to,
它主要是……我的意思是，我们确实经常有名人。但那是知情的。是的，知情的。或者，你知道，只是……你知道，史蒂夫·马丁和马丁·肖特去年做了。霍华德·斯特恩在顶部作为一对一采访做了。你们任何一个人如果想做都可以，
but I know you don't. Yes, please. That's fine, too. But, you know, it's mostly for people who want to understand what happened during the last week and have someone explain to them with their perspective, you know? It's great. Hey, Bill, how do you stay educated?
但我知道你们不想。是的，请。那也很好。但是，你知道，它主要是为那些想了解上周发生了什么，并希望有人用他们的视角向他们解释的人准备的，你知道吗？这很棒。嘿，比尔，你是如何保持受教育的？
You're so courageous that you have, you know, you could have these idiots on if you wanted dummies like us. But you don't, you have people that are incredibly well-informed and you go up against them at times if you don't agree with them. And to do that in an intelligent way, which you have done for God knows how many years, you need to be incredibly well-informed. Where do you find the time to do that?
你太勇敢了，你有，你知道，如果你愿意，你可以邀请这些白痴，像我们这样的笨蛋。但你没有，你有非常见多识广的人，如果你不同意他们，你有时会反驳他们。要以一种聪明的方式做到这一点，你已经做了天知道多少年了，你需要非常见多识广。你在哪里找到时间做这些的？
Yeah, I'm always one of that, too. Oh, yeah, Bill, please tell these two guys about the marvels of reading. Yeah, first of all, you guys, stop with the false modesty. Oh, we're just stupid guys. You're not, you're very bright guys. You have to be very successful, very successful. We'd like to be brighter in some other areas. I certainly would love to be brighter in politics like you are.
是的，我也总是那样。哦，是的，比尔，请告诉这两个家伙阅读的奇迹。是的，首先，你们，停止那种虚伪的谦虚。哦，我们只是愚蠢的家伙。你们不是，你们是非常聪明的家伙。你们必须非常成功，非常成功。我们想在其他领域更聪明一些。我当然很想在政治上像你一样聪明。
But where do you, how do you do it? I'm not buying your I'm so stupid act. You're not stupid and no one thinks you're stupid. But as far as keeping up, you know, it is a bit of, what's a challenge nowadays is to read anything where you think, oh, okay, that's the full story. My problem with media is that everybody's in their own little silo now. If I see something on MSNBC, and I'm a Fox, I don't really ever watch Fox,
但你在哪里，你是怎么做到的？我不买你那套“我很蠢”的表演。你不蠢，没人觉得你蠢。但就跟上进度而言，你知道，这有点，现在的挑战是阅读任何东西，你会想，哦，好吧，那是完整的故事。我对媒体的问题是，每个人现在都在自己的小筒仓里。如果我在MSNBC上看到什么，而我是福克斯的，我其实从来不看福克斯，
but if I do, I know it's only half the story. It's like, oh, okay, there's something I know you're not telling me because it doesn't feed into your narrative. Because the media is about, it's not about truth anymore. It's about, this is our narrative. So is what you're telling me true? Well, it's probably partly true, but I'd have to really work hard to find out the full story.
但如果我看了，我知道那只是故事的一半。就像，哦，好吧，我知道有些事情你没告诉我，因为它不符合你的叙述。因为媒体是关于，它不再是关于真相了。它是关于，这是我们的叙述。那么你告诉我的东西是真的吗？嗯，它可能部分是真的，但我必须非常努力才能找出完整的故事。
That's what pisses me off about the media. So then you got to read two or three articles to make sure it's fully vetted or I'm sure you're fully staffed and all that. Right, you cannot trust anybody to give you the full story. Very few anyway. You know, there's, I just, by the way, just recently, not even before I knew you were doing this, I rewatched your first appearance on The Tonight Show with Johnny Carson.
这就是媒体让我生气的地方。所以你必须阅读两三篇文章以确保它完全经过审查，或者我相信你人员充足等等。对，你不能相信任何人会给你完整的故事。反正很少。你知道，我刚刚，顺便说一句，就在最近，甚至在我知道你要做这个之前，我重看了你第一次出现在《今夜秀》上，和约翰尼·卡森一起。
And it was fantastic. Wow. And even then you didn't shy away from everything that we started talking about, politics, sex, religion, whatever it is. And I love that joke that you said. Did you say sexy religion? Because what's your sexy religion? What's your sex?
那太棒了。哇。即使在那时，你也没有回避我们开始谈论的所有事情，政治、性、宗教，无论是什么。我喜欢你说的那个笑话。你是说性与宗教吗？因为什么是你的性宗教？什么是你的性？
What do you think is the sexiest religion? No, but wait. Let's go around. Let's go around the horn. No, that's a good one. Let's go around the horn. We'll go around the horn. What do you think is the sexiest religion?
你认为什么是性感的宗教？不，但等等。让我们轮流来。让我们轮流来。不，那是个好问题。让我们轮流来。我们轮流来。你认为什么是性感的宗教？
And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Hey, Bill, if you're going to do a show that wasn't about politics, what other subject captures your fancy? Say show tunes, say show tunes. Well, I started a podcast. I don't know when this is airing. It may have started airing.
我们马上回来。现在回到节目。嘿，比尔，如果你要做一个不是关于政治的节目，还有什么主题能吸引你的兴趣？说是音乐剧，说是音乐剧。嗯，我开了一个播客。我不知道这是什么时候播出的。它可能已经开始播出了。
Oh, yeah. It's called Club Random. Club Random. Tell us about what it is. Well, it's funny because what you just said, the last, I would say, I don't know, four or five years, people have been saying to me like we're out to dinner or something. And they'd be like, you should do a podcast.
哦，是的。它叫Club Random。Club Random。告诉我们它是什么。嗯，这很有趣，因为你刚才说的，最后，我会说，我不知道，四五年，人们一直对我说，就像我们出去吃饭什么的。他们会说，你应该做一个播客。
And I'd say, what are you talking about? I have a show. Why would I do a podcast? And they're like, because we just had this dinner. And, you know, you were so interesting on all these topics. And they're not things that you talk about on your show. You know, we were talking about sex and romance and bliss and that and health and all these other things.
我会说，你在说什么？我有一个节目。我为什么要开播客？他们说，因为我们刚吃了这顿饭。而且，你知道，你在所有这些话题上都很有趣。而且它们不是你在节目中谈论的事情。你知道，我们在谈论性、浪漫、幸福、健康以及所有其他事情。
And I'd like to hear you talk about that. So I was like, yeah, sure. And then it got to be kind of a drum beat. So I finally went, oh, maybe I am being thick about this. And I have this place here. Right. And there's a property. There's a little funky old clubhouse on it.
我想听你谈论那个。所以我当时想，是的，当然。然后它变成了一种鼓点。所以我终于想，哦，也许我在这一点上很迟钝。我在这里有这个地方。对。有一个房产。上面有一个古怪的老会所。
I shot there when we were doing the show real time, when we were doing it during the pandemic. That's where we shot the interviews. And it's kind of a pool table in a bar. It's really kind of cool. And we kind of, at some point, it became club random and kind of into a club. And we get your no bullshit approach to many, many subjects and topics. Yeah, good.
当我们在做《马赫脱口秀》时，当我们在疫情期间做它时，我在那里拍摄。那就是我们拍摄采访的地方。它有点像台球桌和酒吧。它真的很酷。我们在某种程度上，它变成了Club Random，变成了一个俱乐部。我们得到了你对许多许多主题和话题的“不废话”方法。是的，很好。
Yeah. So I can just sit down and talk with people one on one. I mean, my show is mostly a panel show. It's either me straight to camera or it's a panel. There's not a lot. There's one at the top, but it's brief. And it's very often somebody like a governor or somebody, you know, a little more formal.
是的。所以我可以坐下来和人们一对一地交谈。我的意思是，我的节目主要是小组讨论节目。要么是我直接对着镜头，要么是小组讨论。没有太多。顶部有一个，但很简短。而且通常是像州长之类的人，你知道，稍微正式一点。
You do great with those, though. Those are awesome. You guys would be good on this. Yeah. Come over to club random. Will, it's across the fucking street. I know, I know. It's so close.
不过你做得很好。那些太棒了。你们在上面会表现得很好。是的。来Club Random吧。威尔，就在该死的街对面。我知道，我知道。太近了。
And it would be less political than this is, because this is not political. Let me ask you, speaking of club random in your podcast, where does Jimmy Valley fit? The great Jimmy Valley fit into all of this. You know, we all love Jimmy Valley. Well, you know, he's my best friend for 40 years. Yeah.
而且它会比这个更不政治化，因为这不是政治性的。让我问你，说到Club Random和你的播客，吉米·瓦利（Jimmy Valley）在哪里？伟大的吉米·瓦利适合这一切。你知道，我们都爱吉米·瓦利。嗯，你知道，他是我40年的好朋友。对。
Is that true? Yeah. We go to Hawaii every year together. No, I didn't know that. Yeah. That's great. Oh, yeah. And I know he is the axis of wonderful as far as arrested
那是真的吗？是的。我们每年一起去夏威夷。不，我不知道。对。那太棒了。哦，是的。我知道他是《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）的中心，这是我最喜欢的节目之一。当然，我相信这就是为什么你们两个关系这么好，这么多年了。这肯定不是肖恩和我们在一起的原因。你知道，我从来没看过一集。不。对。但我的意思是，那个节目是天才。
development goes, which one of my favorite shows of all time. And of course, I'm sure that's why you two guys are so close as big as all those years. It's certainly not why Sean hangs out with us. You know, I've never seen an episode. No. Right. But I mean, that show was genius.
你们在上面是天才。我的意思是，真的，那是我最喜欢的节目之一。我可以一遍又一遍地看。它们太密集了。它们太密集了。你见过米切尔吗？你见过吗？你一定见过米切尔。
And you guys were genius on it. I mean, really, that's one of my faves. I can watch them over and over. They're so dense. They're so dense. Have you met Mitchell? Have you? You must have met Mitchell.
是的，当然他认识我。因为吉米在他的后院有这些沙龙，特别是在疫情期间，我们只能坐在外面。我给了他那个名字。我说，你应该叫它沙龙，我们会邀请人们。米奇总是在那里。
Yes, of course he knows me. Because Jimmy has these salons in his backyard, especially when the pandemic was going on and we could only sit outside. And I gave him that name. I said, you should call it a salon and that we would have people. Mitch was always there.
那两个家伙，世界上最伟大的两个家伙。我不知道。就像我总是想象你一直在阅读。我无法想象你坐着看。就像你看很多节目和电影之类的吗？就像，我宁愿读点什么。是的。看电视，首先，电视，今天的孩子们不明白
Those two guys, two of the greatest guys in the world. I don't know. Like I always picture you just reading constantly. I can't picture you sitting watch. Like do you watch a lot of shows and movies and stuff for you? Like, I'd rather read something. Yeah. Watching TV, first of all, TV, the kids today don't understand
电视是多么美妙、神奇和重要。他们中的一些人甚至没有电视。他们看那个东西，无论他们在手机上看什么。我的床尾有一台大、漂亮、华丽的电视。我一天的结束总是看电视。那很好。我一天结束时必须看至少一个小时的电视，至少。
how wonderful and amazing and vital TV is. Some of them don't even have them. They watch the thing, whatever they watch on their phone. I have a big ass, nice, gorgeous TV at the end of my bed. The end of my day is always watching TV. That's good. I must watch TV at the end of the day for at least an hour, at least.
无脑的东西？不。是的。嗯，不令人不安。我曾经看过一集《黑道家族》，琼斯的手把一个妓女打得半死，我那天晚上整晚都没睡着。太可怕了。
Mindless stuff? No. Yes. Well, not disturbing. I once watched an episode of the Sopranos, where Jones hands beat the shit out of a hooker and I couldn't sleep that whole night. It was terrible.
所以没有那样的东西。所以你看像真人秀之类的？嗯，我的注意力持续时间很短。所以我看五种不同东西的20分钟。但这就是我说的。但这就是我说的。如果我们从五点，因为还不晚，到晚上10点在你家闲逛，
So nothing like that. So you watch like reality TV? Well, I have a very bad attention span. So I'll watch 20 minutes of five different things. But that's what I'm saying. But that's what I'm saying. If we were to hang out at your house from five, because it's not late, to 10 o'clock at night,
而你的注意力持续时间，如果不是看那种东西，它会去哪里？那你去读书吗？让我给你我的时间表。在《马赫脱口秀》制作期间的周中，我每天晚上都工作。我周中从不出门。我每天晚上都在做节目。
and your attention span, where does it go to if it's not watching something like that? Do you go read then? Let me give you my schedule. During the week when real time is in production, I work every night. I never go out during the week. I'm working on the show every night.
我的意思是，那要么是阅读要么是写作。周一是一个繁重的写作之夜。周四，节目播出的前一天，把那个节目放在一起需要很多小时。把最终的编辑放在一起需要大约20个小时，大约是六到八分钟。但是，你知道，所以我喜欢那个。我喜欢工作。
I mean, that is either reading or writing. Monday is a heavy writing night. Thursday, the night before the show, it takes a lot of hours to put that show together. It takes like 20 hours just to put the final editorial together, which is about six to eight minutes. But, you know, so I like that. I like working.
现在我们周三做播客，比如六点到八点，因为我喜欢黑暗和Club Random。当然。这是一个夜间电影。没人喜欢去白天的俱乐部。这是关于它的唯一一点。绝对。当他们尝试圣特罗佩时，就像一个白天的俱乐部。
Now we do the podcast Wednesday, like at six to eight, because I like a dark and club random. Sure. This is a night film. Nobody likes to go to a daytime club. That's the only thing about it. Absolutely. When they try Saint Tropez, it's like a daytime club.
现在带着白天的香槟滚开吧。除非你整晚没睡。我想那是例外。你有没有去过拉斯维加斯的，你知道，白天的泳池派对？没有。没有？没有。
Now fuck off with the daytime champagne. Unless you've stayed up all night. I guess that's different. Of course that's the exception. Have you ever been to a Las Vegas, you know, pool party in the day? No. No? No.
你确实有很多孩子。所以，好吧，就像他们在所有酒店都有这些泳池派对，人们，你可以看出就像中午。他们还没睡觉。他们站在泳池里。110度，没有防晒霜。那些家伙一直在用类固醇，你知道，因为他们是强壮的肌肉男。
You do have a lot of kids. So, okay, it's like they have these pool parties, all the hotels where the people, and you can tell it's like noon. They haven't been to sleep yet. They're standing in the pool. It's 110 degrees, no sunscreen. The guys have been on steroids, you know, because they're big, muscly men.
我的意思是，他们喝醉了，一船的酒。他们可能，你知道，用一张脏的20美元钞票从某人的屁股上吸食可卡因，他们很好。别再担心新冠了，好吗？现在，我在瓶装服务开始前就退出了派对游戏。你能带我了解一下瓶装服务以及它是如何流行的吗？告诉我我理解得对不对。预订俱乐部桌子的唯一方法是你承诺瓶装服务，
I mean, they're drunk, a boatload of liquor. They probably, you know, snorted Coke off somebody's ass through a dirty $20 bill, and they're fine. Stop worrying about COVID, okay? Now, I got out of the party game right before bottle service started. Can you walk me through bottle service and how that caught on? And tell me if I have this right. The only way to book a table at a club is if you commit to bottle service,
也就是一瓶非常好的伏特加。我能说吗，我很高兴我们在录音。五千块钱给你那瓶伏特加、四个杯子和一桶冰，你就可以拥有那个卡座。那是，那是，那是对的吗？嗯，杰森，我也很多年没有去过俱乐部了，除了我自己的Club Random。那是4月15日？那是4月15日吗？
which is a bottle of really nice vodka. Can I just say, I'm so fucking glad we're recording this. Five grand gets you the bottle of vodka, four glasses, and a bucket of ice, and you can have the booth. Is that, is that, is that about right? Well, Jason, I also have not been in clubs except my own club random for many, many years. And that's April 15th? Is that April 15th?
不，那是特别节目。那是我的HBO单口喜剧特别节目。哦天哪，抱歉。我太困惑了。播客可能到时候已经播出了。抱歉，你仍然，比尔，你仍然必须带杰森了解什么是俱乐部，什么是俱乐部。不，特别是瓶装服务。我知道什么是瓶装服务，是的。这是一个很大的数字。我的意思是，它不是，它不是那么复杂。
No, that's the special. That's my HBO standup special. Oh God, sorry. I get so confused. The podcast may already be on by the time. Sorry, you still, Bill, you still have to walk Jason through what a club, what a club is. No, bottle service in particular. I know what bottle service is, yes. It's a big number. I mean, it's not that, it's not that complicated.
它，他们试图让你花很多钱买一张好桌子。谁会同意花5000美元买一瓶伏特加和一个卡座？俱乐部里成吨的人想用他们爸爸的钱给女孩留下深刻印象。怎么会是五千块？你以为500块钱是上限。他们最低涨到了五千块。不，是那些洗劫了主权财富基金的家伙，他们住在这里去上大学。有那么多吗？加利福尼亚，洛杉矶这里有这么多信托基金宝宝。
It's, they're trying to get you to spend a lot of money to buy a good table. Who would ever say yes to spend $5,000 on a bottle of vodka and a booth? Tons of people in clubs who want to impress girls with their daddy's money. How is it five grand? You'd think 500 would be about the ceiling. They went to five grand at a minimum. No, it's guys who have fleeced sovereign wealth funds and they're living over here going to college. There's that many of them? There's so many trust fund babies out here in California, in Los Angeles.
如果你出去，再说一次，我不去那种地方，已经很多年了，但全是那个。全是那些孩子，他们在这个年纪不可能有那种钱，除非那是他们爸爸的钱，而他们正在为你花钱。你喜欢拉斯维加斯吗，比尔？你喜欢在那里表演吗？你喜欢俱乐部吗？你去的时候赌博吗？我不赌博，但我表演。过去五年左右，我每年在大幻影酒店（Mirage）大约六次。我喜欢那个。那是一个很棒的房间。那是一家很棒的酒店。我从讨厌观众，因为当我第一次在拉斯维加斯表演时，我是一个开场演员。
If you ever go out, and again, I don't go out to places like that and happen for many, many years, but it's all that. It's all these kids who could not possibly have that kind of money at that age, except it's their daddy's money and they're spending it for you. Do you like Vegas, Bill? Do you like playing there? Do you like clubs? Do you gamble when you go? I do not gamble, but I play it. I've been at the Mirage for about the last five years, about six times a year. I love that. It's a great room. It's a great hotel. I went from hating the audience because when I first played Las Vegas, I was an opening actor.
我在1982年为戴安娜·罗斯开场，那很痛苦。首先，那就像拉斯维加斯的死球时代。就像鼠帮的末尾，就像辛纳屈在那里，但他80岁了。没有夜总会。那一点也不好玩，他们不知道我是谁。在戴安娜·罗斯入场前的20分钟里，有一个笨蛋站在人群面前。现在，它就像全国最时髦的人群。真的吗？是的。
I opened for Diana Ross in 1982, and it was painful. First of all, that was like the dead ball era in Vegas. Like the end of the rat pack, like Sinatra was there, but he was 80. There was no nightclubs. It was just not fun, and they didn't know who I was. There was a Porsch muck standing in front of the crowd for 20 minutes while they filed in for Diana Ross. Now, it's like the hippest crowd in the country. Really? Yes.
哇。部分原因是它现在本身就是一座城市，拉斯维加斯。它是一个相当大的城市。你可以从当地人那里吸引很大比例的人群，但也只是，这就是来看我的人。我的意思是，还有很多其他选择。如果他们愿意，他们可以看到该死的魔术或海豚之类的东西。但如果他们来我的节目，他们想要那个。如果可以的话，我会表演两倍多。你为什么不赌博？有糟糕的情况吗？这就是为什么我不再做了，但从来没有被它吸引，还是你受伤了？
Wow. Part of it is it's a city in itself now, Las Vegas. It's a fairly big city. You can draw a good percentage of the crowd from locals, but also just like, that's who's going to go see me. I mean, there's plenty of other options. They could see fucking magic or a dolphin or some shit if they wanted to. But if they're coming to my show, they want that. And I would play it twice as much if I could. How come you don't gamble? Was there a bad situation? That's why I don't do it anymore, but was never attracted to it or did you get hurt?
这很蠢。他们称之为赌博。他们应该直接称之为慢慢输钱。我讨厌输钱。再说一次，我需要你带我了解这个。怎么会这么难？在大多数赌注上，这基本上是一个50-50的提议。不，当然不是。你可以坐在体育博彩区。那是50-50。不是。没有什么东西是50-50。得了吧。这就是为什么赌场在赚钱。这就是为什么我认为赌场在赚钱。赌场赚钱的原因是每个人离开去拉斯维加斯时都带着他们愿意输掉的承诺金额，在输掉那笔钱之前他们不会离开桌子。
It's stupid. They call it gambling. They should just call it losing money slowly. I hate losing money. Again, I need you to walk me through this. How is it so hard? It's basically a 50-50 proposition on most bets. No, of course it's not. You could sit in the sports book. It's 50-50. It's not. Nothing is 50-50. Come on. That's why the house is making money. Here's why I think the house makes money. The reason the house makes money is because everybody leaves to go to Vegas with a committed amount of money they're willing to lose and they don't leave the table until they lose that money.
如果你考虑你愿意赢多少，当你达到那个数字时离开，那你就会赚钱。他们赚钱的原因是赔率稍微对他们有利。如果你有数百万数百万的赌注，即使是50-149，随着时间的推移，你会发财，而其他人会输掉他们的房子。这就是为什么我认为这很令人沮丧。你说你喜欢在拉斯维加斯表演。去那里真是令人沮丧。我看到人们失去了他们拥有的一切。等等。肖恩，我以前和你去过拉斯维加斯，你就像该死的拆分A，一次又一次，突然之间你一手牌有3500美元。你就像，加注！全部加注！
If you think about what you're willing to win and leave when you hit that number, then you'd make money. The reason they make money is because the odds are slightly in their favor. If you have millions and millions of bets, even if it's 50-149, over time you're going to make a fortune and other people are going to lose their house. That's why I think it's depressing. You say you love playing Vegas. I'm so depressing to go there. I see people losing everything they have. Wait a second. Sean, I've been to Vegas with you before and you're like fucking splitting aces and again and again and all of a sudden you get $3,500 on a hand. You're like, hit it! Hit it all!
这是真的。这是真的。我真是令人沮丧。如果你去过大西洋城，你看到人们只是去，他们在轮盘赌上赢了。在拉斯维加斯的轮盘赌，每个人都玩得很开心，他们都在互相拥抱。就像广告一样，对吧？每个人都在欢呼、叫喊、击掌。在大西洋城，他们赢了，他们就像，我受不了再过一周了。比尔，你提到你说死球。那是对棒球的引用。
This is true. This is true. I'm fucking depressing. If you've been to Atlantic City and you see people just go and they win at the Roulette. Roulette in Vegas, everybody's having a blast and they're all hugging each other. It's like a commercial, right? And everybody's hooting, hollering, high-fiving. In Atlantic City, they win and they're like, I can't take another week. Bill, you mentioned you said dead ball. That was a reference to baseball.
是的，你是个大棒球迷。我觉得是的。直到去年，我还是大都会队的小股东。是的，我听说了。那很酷。是的，但现在好多了，因为我不必担心财务问题。疫情期间很糟糕，因为我们没有打2020年的前100场比赛。然后当我们打最后60场时，看台上没有人买热狗。你是怎么得到机会得到它的一部分的
Yes, you're a big baseball fan. I feel like yes. I was a minority owner of the Mets up until last year. Yeah, I heard that. That's cool. Yeah, but it's much nicer now because I don't have to worry about the finances. It was horrible during the pandemic because we didn't play the first 100 games of 2020. And then when we did play the last 60, there was no one in the stands buying hot dogs. How did that come about you getting an opportunity to get a piece of it
然后你是怎么剥离的？嗯，我在报纸上读到的。那是2011年《纽约时报》的头版故事。大都会队陷入了巨大的财务困境，他们正在出售，上面说球队的40%。他们正在寻找大约八或十个投资者，上面说了它可能花费多少。我当时想，嗯，我没有赡养费、孩子或愚蠢的爱好。我不收集汽车、摩托车、绘画、珠宝、妓女或可卡因。我实际上存了我的便士，我实际上可以买。
and then how did it come about you divesting? Well, I read about it in the paper. It was a front page story in the New York Times in 2011. The Mets were in great financial trouble and they were selling, it said 40% of the team. They were looking for about eight or 10 investors and it said how much it might cost. And I was like, huh, I don't have alimony or kids or stupid hobbies. I don't collect cars or motorcycles or paintings or jewelry or hookers or cocaine. I've actually saved my pennies and I could actually buy.
我实际上可以做到这一点，但我当时肯定会有成千上万比我更有钱的人先排队。不。仅仅一个月后，大都会队当时身上有那么大的臭味，我当时想，嗯，你知道吗？运动队永远不会贬值，特别是在纽约的棒球特许经营权。你去年刚卖掉它吗？嗯，史蒂夫·科恩，现在棒球界最富有的老板，他进来了，买下了整个球队。所以他从多数股东威尔庞（Wilpons）那里买下了它，然后他买断了所有少数股东。我们没有选择，我也不想要选择。
I could actually do this, but I was like sure that there were going to be a thousand people richer than me who'd be online first. No. Just a month later, the Mets had such a stink on them at the time and I was like, well, you know what? Sports teams never go down in value, especially the baseball franchise in New York. Did you just sell it last year? Well, Steve Cohen, now the richest owner in baseball, he came in and bought the whole team. So he bought it from the majority owners, the Wilpons, and then he bought out all the minority owners. We didn't have a choice and I didn't want a choice.
我很高兴能摆脱它，因为再说一次，现在我可以只是一个粉丝。我不必担心他们的劳工问题或大都会队度过一个失败的赛季并赔钱。你赚了一点还是赔了一点？哦，我赚了很多。哦，太棒了。但即使我在疫情期间赔了钱，因为再说一次，我知道一个球队，这是纽约的国家联盟特许经营权。他们不再制造了，棒球深深地融入了人们的……我和我父亲去了第一场比赛，你永远无法给那个定价，
I was so glad to be out of it because again, now I can just be a fan. I don't have to worry about their labor problems or the Mets having a losing year and losing money. Did you make a little bit or did you lose a little bit? Oh, I made a lot. Oh, great. But even with what I lost during the pandemic, because again, I knew that a team, this is the National League franchise in New York. They're not making anymore and baseball is so woven into people's... My father and I went to the first game and that you're never going to be able to put a value on that,
我很高兴能从中解脱出来，因为现在我又可以只做一个球迷了。我不必再担心他们的劳资问题，也不必担心大都会队战绩不佳而亏钱。你赚了一点还是亏了一点？哦，我赚了很多。哦，太棒了。但即使算上我在疫情期间亏损的部分，因为我再次意识到，这是一支纽约的国家联盟球队。他们不会再有更多这样的球队了，而且棒球已经深深融入了人们的……我和我父亲去看了第一场比赛，那是你永远无法用金钱来衡量的。
but teams just always go up. So I think what the Mets were valued at when I bought in was like 750 million, which was way low. And then they sold for like 2.4 billion or something. After how many years? Like 10. Wow. And did Seinfeld buy a piece of it too? No, he didn't want it.
但球队总是会升值。所以我认为我入股大都会队时，它的估值大概是7.5亿美元，这太低了。后来他们以24亿美元左右的价格卖掉了。过了多少年？大概10年吧。哇。宋飞也买了一部分吗？不，他没想要。
No, he should have. He's way richer than me. Yeah. Now, did you have voting rights? Could you email the GM and say, draft this guy? No, but I was invited to the owner's meetings. I went to one. It was so boring.
不，他本该买的。他比我有钱多了。那么，你有投票权吗？你可以给总经理发邮件说，选这个人吗？没有，但我受邀参加过老板会议。我去过一次。太无聊了。
It was a lot about parking and hot dogs. It's like, oh, God, I wish I had... Parking hot dogs. Yeah, it was really boring. Did you ever just for a goof try to recommend some shitty idea about a mascot or something just to see if you get a reaction? No, I didn't want to piss them off. It was great. I had a parking spot.
大部分时间都在讨论停车位和热狗。我就想，天哪，我真希望我有……停车位和热狗。是啊，真的很无聊。你有没有试过为了好玩，建议一些关于吉祥物之类的烂点子，看看他们会有什么反应？没有，我不想惹恼他们。这很棒。我有一个停车位。
You know, you'd go in the special entrance, you know, you had a box. This is my dream. And now a word from our sponsor. All right. Back to the show. Hey, Bill. Now speaking of parking hot dogs, do you have a lady in your life? What's going on?
你知道，你可以走特殊入口，你知道，你有一个包厢。这是我的梦想。现在是赞助商时间。好了。回到节目。嘿，比尔。说到停车位和热狗，你生命中有另一半吗？最近怎么样？
Mom, I told you I didn't want to talk about that. Did you? Okay. No, but I was going to ask the same thing and you don't have to answer it if you don't want. But just as we all are getting older, is any of that changing at all in your brain? We're just like, maybe there is something to settling down or something or absolutely not. I'll certainly be happy to answer that in the abstract. There's nothing to settling down.
妈，我告诉过你我不想谈这个。你说了吗？好吧。不，但我本来也要问同样的问题，如果你不想回答也没关系。但随着我们都变老了，你的大脑里有没有什么改变？比如，你会觉得安定下来或许有什么意义，还是完全没有？我当然很乐意从抽象的角度回答这个问题。安定下来毫无意义。
For me, it's a very personal thing. Of course. I like to be settled and some people like to be married and some people don't. And I'm one of those people who don't. And, you know, I feel like that's just personal. Whatever concessions that you make for being married, I assume what people keep doing it, there must be some compensating reasons that make it all worthwhile not to have sex. When you talk about...
对我来说，这是非常私人的事情。当然。我喜欢安定，有些人喜欢结婚，有些人不喜欢。而我属于不喜欢的那类人。而且，你知道，我觉得这纯属个人选择。无论你为了结婚做出什么让步，我假设人们之所以坚持这样做，一定有一些补偿性的理由，让这一切变得值得，哪怕没有性生活。当你谈到……
I can't fucking think of what it is, but I'm sure there must be one. Yeah. When you talk, though, about how it doesn't get easier and stuff, what are the things that you think about now that are like bummed you out about getting older? I agree with you, by the way. I am feeling that thing of I care less and less what people think. Honestly, these guys know I could give up shit about a lot of stuff and I have a bad attitude a lot of the time. Boy.
我他妈想不出那是什么，但我肯定一定有。是啊。不过，当你谈到变老并没有变得更容易之类的话题时，现在有哪些事情会让你因为变老而感到沮丧？顺便说一句，我同意你的观点。我确实感觉到我越来越不在乎别人的想法了。老实说，这些家伙知道我对很多事情都无所谓，而且我大部分时间态度都很差。天哪。
Yeah. Take a chill pill, man. No, man. No. I refuse. No, I mean, look, thankfully I can do everything I always did pretty much the same. So that has not caught up with me yet. But I am under no illusion that that is next.
是啊。冷静点，伙计。不，伙计。不。我拒绝。不，我是说，看，谢天谢地，我还能做我一直以来做的所有事情，基本都一样。所以这一点还没追上我。但我并不抱有幻想，那会是接下来的事。
I can't be... I mean, I could still play basketball, right? Yeah. But will that be happening when I'm 80? I don't know. And of course, the other thing about aging that's tough is that you just... I mean, let's be honest, you just look worse. Yeah.
我不能……我是说，我还能打篮球，对吧？是啊。但当我80岁时还能打吗？我不知道。当然，变老还有一点很艰难，那就是你只是……我是说，老实说，你看起来确实变差了。是啊。
I mean, you can look good for your age, but it's just the corruption of the flesh is just going to happen. You look great, though. I would say you look better now than you did 20 years ago. Yeah, you look exactly the same. And then when you put your glasses on, which you were sort of cutely sheepish about the beginning of the season, you looked fantastic. You wear glasses. Yeah, well, those are good-looking glasses.
我是说，你可以看起来比实际年龄年轻，但肉体的腐朽终究会发生。不过你看起来很棒。我会说你现在看起来比20年前更好。是啊，你看起来一模一样。当你戴上眼镜时，你在本季初还有点可爱地羞涩，你看起来棒极了。你戴眼镜。是啊，嗯，那是很好看的眼镜。
Well, I appreciate that because it was a... That speaking of aging, that's a great thing to bring up because even though I understand and a lot of people said, oh, I like the glasses, for me, there was something about it psychologically. I had been on TV for 28 years without glasses and somehow that fucked with my head in a giant way. It was like this concession that I... Because I'm telling you, for two years, I really couldn't see the prompter. If I hadn't written a lot of the material myself or at least rewrote it, I probably couldn't have gotten through it. And I would go into...
嗯，我很感激，因为那是一个……说到变老，这是一个很好的话题，因为尽管我理解，很多人说，哦，我喜欢这副眼镜，但对我来说，心理上有些东西。我戴着眼镜在电视上露面28年了，不知何故，这在很大程度上搞乱了我的头脑。这就像是一种让步，我……因为我告诉你，有两年，我真的看不清提词器。如果不是我自己写了很多材料，或者至少重写了它，我可能无法完成。我会走进……
Would they just abuse big font? No, because then you can't get enough writing on the thing. So you have to deal with the normal-sized font. But I was just... In rehearsal, I'd be like... I'm sure they were laughing at me behind the cameras because I was just struggling and I finally had... And I've had three Lasics, so I couldn't go back to that. Three!
他们会滥用大字体吗？不，因为那样你就没法在上面写足够多的内容了。所以你必须处理正常大小的字体。但我只是……在排练时，我会……我敢肯定他们在摄像机后面嘲笑我，因为我一直在挣扎，我终于不得不……而且我做过三次激光手术，所以我不能再做那个了。三次！
Wow! I had one and loved it. I've had two. So I had to break down and do the glasses. Were there a couple of years where you were like, just come closer and go wider. Come closer and just go wider. That's just like, we can't get any closer, Bill. Yeah, that was it.
哇！我做过一次，很喜欢。我做过两次。所以我不得不妥协，戴上了眼镜。有没有那么几年，你就像是，再靠近一点，再宽一点。再靠近一点，再宽一点。就像是，我们不能再靠近了，比尔。是啊，就是那样。
I did everything I could to forestall it. And then when it happened, it just was something psychological with me. It was like the end of an era. You've passed this milestone, you are officially now. And of course it happened right when I was officially a senior citizen. 65. So, you know... You're 65?
我尽我所能去阻止它。然后当它发生时，对我来说就是心理上的某种东西。就像一个时代的终结。你跨过了这个里程碑，你现在正式成为……当然，它发生在我正式成为老年人的时候。65岁。所以，你知道……你65岁了？
You look fucking great, though. 66. Wow! Good for you, man. Yeah. Now tell me, these guys know I like to dig in about workout regiments and diet and stuff. I'll bet you're pretty disciplined about exercising and what you put in your face. Beyond disciplined.
不过你看起来真他妈棒。66岁。哇！为你高兴，伙计。是啊。现在告诉我，这些家伙知道我喜欢深挖锻炼计划和饮食之类的东西。我敢打赌你对锻炼和吃进嘴里的东西非常自律。比自律更甚。
That is one thing you have to do. If you want to live the kind of club random life I live. You know, you're not going to... Not to be confused with the special on April 15th. No, that's it. Exactly. Yes, but I've never been a foodie, so it's good because... Yeah, but you like to smoke and it gets real snacky late at night.
这是你必须做的一件事。如果你想过我这种“随机俱乐部”的生活。你知道，你不会……不要和4月15日的特别节目混淆。不，就是那个。没错。是的，但我从来不是个美食家，所以这很好，因为……是啊，但你喜欢抽烟，而且深夜会很想吃零食。
How do you get past that? Well, first of all, I think people think I smoke way more pot than I do. Yeah. I don't smoke every day. Never have. Never want to. That's too much. This is controversial already.
你是怎么克服那个的？嗯，首先，我认为人们以为我抽的大麻比我实际抽的多。是啊。我不是每天都抽。从来没有。也不想。那太多了。这已经很有争议了。
Yeah. No, I mean, when you smoke that much, it doesn't work. And I want it to work. I need pot. I'll admit that. I need pot for some very vital things that I do that I really don't want to do without it. So I save it for that. Cheech and Chong movies.
是啊。不，我是说，当你抽那么多时，它就不起作用了。而我希望它起作用。我需要大麻。我承认这一点。我需要大麻来做一些我必须做的非常重要的事情，而我真的不想在没有它的情况下做。所以我把它留给那些事情。Cheech and Chong电影。
What? Cheech and Chong movies. Yeah, you can't watch those sober. I need it for that. I know. See, that's something I would never do is get on and watch a movie. No, a lot of people do. I know.
什么？Cheech and Chong电影。是啊，你不能清醒地看那些电影。我需要它来做那个。我知道。看，那是我永远不会做的事情，就是抽了之后看电影。不，很多人会。我知道。
I use it for, like, more uplifting things, more important things. Like driving. Quickly. I always have people, Bill, I always have people who go like, oh, man, this, you see that movie? Blah, blah, blah. I go, no, yeah, this is fucking great. I go, were you high? They go, yeah.
我用它来做一些更令人振奋的事情，更重要的事情。比如开车。快速地。我总是有人，比尔，我总是有人说，哦，伙计，这个，你看到那部电影了吗？等等等等。我说，不，是啊，这他妈太棒了。我说，你当时嗨了吗？他们说，是啊。
I go, I don't want to hear your fucking opinion. I don't want to hear your opinion. Oh, Bill Maher, we don't want to take up any more of your time. I mean, we do. Come on, that's it. I feel like we're just getting juicy with him. Wow. I know.
我说，我不想听你他妈的意见。我不想听你的意见。哦，比尔·马赫，我们不想占用你更多时间了。我是说，我们想。来吧，就这样。我觉得我们才刚跟他聊得起劲。哇。我知道。
You know, when it goes by fast, Bill, it means it was good. Yeah, it's true. I think. I mean, I would be crestfallen if I thought three guys who I admire as much as you, I let down in any way. Oh, you're the sweetest. I love you to death. I think you were amazing.
你知道，当时间过得很快时，比尔，意味着它很棒。是啊，是真的。我想。我是说，如果我觉得我让三个我如此钦佩的家伙失望了，我会很沮丧的。哦，你真是太贴心了。我爱你爱得要死。我觉得你太棒了。
You overdelivered. All right. Well, I'll know that's true if you invite me back. Yes, for sure. Yeah, all right. We could do a two-parter. Yeah, that's how I'll know if that maybe we'll just come over to club rando. I would love that.
你超出了预期。好吧。嗯，如果你们邀请我回来，我就知道那是真的了。是的，当然。是啊，好吧。我们可以做个两集。是啊，这就是我怎么知道的，也许我们会去随机俱乐部。我很乐意。
I could spend an hour talking about religion with you because I. Oh, yes. I sent you an email after this and it just kind of like totally enlightened me. And you've done great things on religion. And you've also played both Larry and Jerry Lewis. So, you know, all the juice. You can only play juice. And comics.
我可以花一个小时和你谈论宗教，因为我。哦，是的。我在那之后给你发了一封邮件，它真的让我完全开悟了。你在宗教方面做了伟大的事情。而且你还扮演过拉里和杰瑞·刘易斯。所以，你知道，所有的精髓。你只能扮演精髓。还有漫画。
By the way, playing another one in this play. A piano playing. I'm playing Oscar Levant in a play out here in Chicago. Oscar Levant. No, refresh my memory. Exactly. I know the name. He will.
顺便说一句，在这部戏里又演了一个。弹钢琴的。我正在芝加哥的一部戏里扮演奥斯卡·黎凡特。奥斯卡·黎凡特。不，帮我回忆一下。没错。我知道这个名字。他会的。
He will. He shows a week. He'll be refreshing your memory at the Steppenwolf Theater. The Goodman. Goodman. The Goodman. He was a pianist, right? He was one of Jack Parr's favorite guests and also a pianist and a drug addict and everything else.
他会的。他一周演出一次。他会在荒原狼剧院帮你回忆起来。古德曼剧院。古德曼。古德曼。他是个钢琴家，对吧？他是杰克·帕尔最喜欢的嘉宾之一，也是一位钢琴家、瘾君子，还有其他一切。
Sounds like we're saying penis. Yeah. And on that note, thank you, Billy. My pleasure. You're so sweet to show. Bill, thanks, man. Congratulations. Thanks so much, Bill.
听起来我们在说阴茎。是啊。说到这里，谢谢你，比利。我的荣幸。你真是太贴心了。比尔，谢谢，伙计。恭喜。非常感谢，比尔。
We'll see you at Club Random. All right. Thank you. Bye, buddy. We'll see you, Bill. Okay. He's that Bill Maher, right? Yeah.
我们在随机俱乐部见。好吧。谢谢。再见，伙计。再见，比尔。好的。他是那个比尔·马赫，对吧？是啊。
The guy is just, he's a big brain. He makes me think. He does make you think. Oh, we speak of the things. Speaking of things. Have you guys tried the new think bars? Not the new thing, but just think bars in general. They are incredible.
这家伙就是，他是个大脑。他让我思考。他确实让你思考。哦，我们谈论这些事情。说到这些事情。你们试过新的Think能量棒了吗？不是新东西，只是Think能量棒。它们太不可思议了。
Wow. The kind that are, the 20 grams of protein and no sugar. Those are my favorite. Can I ask you a question before you go any further? Can I ask you a question? And I want you to be honest. Bill Maher is quite the brain. Jason, I want to ask you a question you need to be honest with me.
哇。那种20克蛋白质且无糖的。那是我的最爱。在你继续之前，我能问你一个问题吗？我能问你一个问题吗？我希望你诚实。比尔·马赫真是个大脑。杰森，我想问你一个问题，你需要对我诚实。
Okay. Did you just run out of think bars? I did. Well, I am, I'm definitely low on think bars because I have at least one think bar a day because when I think about it, you know, health is something you should think about. And then what the best thing to do is to package something that says the word think on it. Because then there's a link there. So when you think, do you think Bill, do you think Bill eats those?
好的。你是不是刚用完Think能量棒？是的。嗯，我，我确实Think能量棒不多了，因为我每天至少吃一根，因为当我想到它时，你知道，健康是你应该思考的事情。然后最好的做法是包装一些写着“思考”这个词的东西。因为那样就有一个联系了。所以当你思考时，你认为比尔，你认为比尔吃那些吗？
Boy, he's, he looks like, I mean, his body, it looks like he's in great shape. He is in great shape. He is in great shape. For like, and he said he's what, 65, 60, he even said, but he looks like. Your memory, your memory is terrible. He just said it. You might need a think bar. I mean, I mean, he's probably having the peanut butter ones.
天哪，他，他看起来，我是说，他的身体，看起来他状态很好。他状态很好。他状态很好。对于像，他说他多少岁，65，60，他甚至说了，但他看起来像。你的记忆力，你的记忆力太差了。他刚说了。你可能需要一根Think能量棒。我是说，我是说，他可能在吃花生酱味的。
Oh my God. This is unbelievable. All right. But wait, but wait a minute. Here's what I love about Bill. And then, and then we can go back to the think bars. No, we cannot go back to it. Okay.
天哪。这太不可思议了。好吧。但等等，但等一下。这就是我喜欢比尔的地方。然后，然后我们可以回到Think能量棒。不，我们不能回到那个。好的。
Then we don't think of it. I'd like to go. Maybe we can talk about cryptocurrency. I'd love some. I'm fresh out of crypto. So Jason, how am I going to get crypto on my net jets? Net jets, the best way to take your family. And listen, and jet edge also.
那我们就不想它了。我想去。也许我们可以谈谈加密货币。我很喜欢。我刚用完加密货币。所以杰森，我怎么在我的NetJets上获得加密货币？NetJets，带你家人旅行的最佳方式。听着，还有Jet Edge也是。
I love jet edge too. Actually, I gotta admit. And you know what they serve on those jets are chips ahoy. And chips ahoy are really, Hey, really reach for the stars, Sean. I do want to say jet edge is actually pretty great. I remember, I remember on Jason, I think we were on a jet edge flight. And it was first of all, it was just, you know, price per hour was amazing.
我也喜欢Jet Edge。其实，我得承认。你知道他们在那些喷气机上提供什么吗？是Chips Ahoy饼干。Chips Ahoy真的很，嘿，真的志存高远，肖恩。我确实想说Jet Edge其实相当不错。我记得，我记得在杰森，我想我们在一次Jet Edge航班上。首先，它只是，你知道，每小时的价格太棒了。
And it was great. The service is incredible. And I remember looking at things like this has gone so smoothly, so quickly. And I quickly look at my Rolex and it tells the time. And I think to myself, is it right? I've crossed how many time zones and the time is so precise. But it was so great when you, when we landed, I got right into my Porsche. Yeah.
而且很棒。服务令人难以置信。我记得看着这些事情，进展得如此顺利，如此迅速。我迅速看了看我的劳力士，它显示了时间。我心想，它是对的吗？我跨越了多少个时区，时间如此精确。但当我们着陆时，那真是太棒了，我直接上了我的保时捷。是啊。
And I drove so fast home. Yeah, you did. Unbelievable. Safely. You got safely home. All right. Sean goes, what have Sean said? And then I got home.
我开车飞快地回家。是啊，你做到了。不可思议。安全地。你安全到家了。好吧。肖恩说，肖恩说了什么？然后我到家了。
And I just, I remember just getting home and saying like, all these twizzlers for me. It's Christmas over. I do want to say this about Bill before we, before we leave is that I love that I mentioned it during the show. I love that he really is truly one of those guys who has his own show who explores both sides of any argument always. And to me is fair about both sides. Well, here's the thing.
我记得刚到家就说，这些Twizzlers是给我的。圣诞节结束了。在离开之前，我确实想关于比尔说这一点，我喜欢我在节目中提到的。我喜欢他确实是那种拥有自己节目的人，他总是探索任何争论的双方。对我来说，他对双方都很公平。嗯，事情是这样的。
He's not scared of, let me just say this. He is a guy who is, he has an opinion on a lot of stuff and he says it. And I think that, you know, part of it is, I don't know if sometimes he says it to instigate conversation, because that's kind of what he does. But also he, he's willing to at least engage on topics that a lot of people don't want to engage on. On both sides too. So I think that would officially make him by curious.
他不怕，让我这么说吧。他是一个，他有很多事情的看法，而且他说了出来。我认为，你知道，部分原因是，我不知道有时他是否为了煽动对话而说，因为这就是他所做的。但他也，他至少愿意参与许多人不想参与的话题。而且是双方的。所以我认为这正式让他变得双向好奇。
At the very least. By intelligent. By the way, Jed Edge, what a way to travel. To close the loop on Jed Edge. Honestly, take your choice. It does make you think about how do you want to travel. If you're going to go mid-hit, it's so much easier if you're bi-costal. Guys, I got to roll X.
至少。双向智能。顺便说一句，Jet Edge，多么好的旅行方式。结束关于Jet Edge的话题。老实说，随你选择。它确实让你思考你想怎么旅行。如果你要进行中途旅行，如果你是双海岸的，那就容易多了。伙计们，我得去买劳力士。
Yeah. I should roll X too. Because I got to go to Daytona pretty soon. Yeah. Roll X Daytona. The best way. Yeah. All right.
是啊。我也应该买劳力士。因为我很快就要去代托纳了。是啊。劳力士代托纳。最好的方式。是啊。好吧。
Well, listen. Yeah. Listen, you can choose to do it the old fashioned way, or you can also think of, you know, you would the, we can be modern and buy crypto, buy crypto now. Buy crypto. Buy it for me. Smart. Nice.
嗯，听着。是啊。听着，你可以选择用老式的方法，或者你也可以考虑，你知道，你可以变得现代一点，买加密货币，现在就买加密货币。买加密货币。帮我买。聪明。不错。
Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice.
聪明。不错。聪明。不错。聪明。不错。聪明。不错。
Smart. Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice. Smart.
聪明。聪明。不错。聪明。不错。聪明。不错。聪明。
Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice.
聪明。不错。聪明。不错。聪明。不错。聪明。不错。
Smart. Thanks. Delicious. Nice. Thank you. Thanks. I'm going to go back to your stuff. Yeah, I got to roll X. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。谢谢。美味。不错。谢谢。谢谢。我要回去处理你的东西了。是啊，我得去买劳力士。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。